what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 20th of september from
the heart of new jersey the joint is
brought to you by draftkings
ufc 266
is coming at you this weekend
nick diaz versus robbie lawler oh [__]
and volkanovsky against ortega oh [__]
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the ufc has a
tremendous [__] offer for you
draftkings is going to give you 150
dollars
in free bets instantly just about a
dollar
on any fight before the main event
what did i say
any fight before the main event
a dollar gets you 150
in free [__] bets now mma isn't you
don't worry about it draftking
sportsbook has you covered they got
great odds and promotions on football
baseball the playoffs are coming up
golf and more with a tremendous [__]
casino
draftkings are safe secure and reliable
the best part is you can withdraw your
cash whenever you want
[Music]
don't miss the action on ufc 266 and
don't miss the action tonight you got
green bay against detroit i don't know
what the line is i don't give a [__]
download the draftking sports book app
right now
use promo code joey tonight and bet a
dollar and you're going to receive 200
football bets plus if you bet a dollar
on the ufc you get
another 150 in ufc bets that's three
[__] 50 in a week they're giving away
at draftkings sportsbook app you got to
be 21 older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only
new customers only winning paid out and
site credits
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details you want to have
a good time draftkings is the answer
but if you got a gambling problem call
1-800 gambler if you're in indiana call
1-800-9
with it but if you're ready to make some
[__] adidas
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now whether it's the football ufc
baseball casino
blackjack they got it all right now
download you a draftking sports book app
draftkings sportsbook app use promo code
joey you understand me
just use promo code joey whether it's
football
ufc or baseball we're going to take care
of you the joint is also brought to you
by my personal favorite
cbd line they got you covered
at every [__] angle do you understand
me whether it's the cbd infused tape the
kinesiology
tape the
the strength cream the 100 milligram
cream the the
pills
i listen they got it all i'm over here
[__] confused i shouldn't be confused
they got it all go to cbdline.com right
now
read the third party lab results read
about cbd
cbn and how they can be an advantage to
you how they've helped me throughout the
surgery and with this anxiety i've been
going through right now go to
cbdline.com
preston joey and get 20 off any product
delivered to your house the gummy bears
with the melatonin are tremendous the
[__] the tincture is tremendous
cbd lion has you covered but it starts
with you going to cbdline.com
and reading and ordering right now go to
cbdline.com right now
and download not download read
about the tablets
the cbd mental gel which is [__]
tremendous
the best balls listen enough go to cbd
lion you're gonna be as surprised as i
was let's get this [__] party
started it's monday
you ain't got time for chitta chatter
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday september the 20th
another fun-filled day here on uncle
joey's [__] joint it was a
great weekend i didn't do dick
i went to a couple softball games my
daughter's softball games i uh
watch some [__] football
i bet the rams you know same [__]
[__]
now it's monday night tonight i got
[__] green bay
against detroit i'm excited thank god
for draftkings for eliminating the
boredom from my life a 25 bet and i have
a great [__] time
i'm a loser but sometimes i went on
accident for example saturday my brother
was going to the yankee game right so he
goes i'm going to yankee game at one
o'clock i don't know who the [__]
they're playing cleveland
so i'm i wake up [__] saturday
morning i got to go to the softball game
at 9 30. then i got to run home
go to the bathroom and shoot back to the
second game i [__] do the first game
i run home
i check the computer i check my emails
and i go let me just see what the line
is on the yankee game
my brother's going at least i have a
good time you know thinking about him
listen you can't bet the [__] yankees
did it the yankees are horrible they're
just [__] horrible i've tried to
watch them during the [__] week
and they're just missing something
listen i'm not a baseball [__]
empresario but i know when you're
missing something when i watch [__]
san francisco that's a great team when i
watch the dodgers
that's a good team you know when i watch
milwaukee houston they're good teams the
yankees are missing something right so
i'm like
even though
i'm just betting 25 hours i'm not in
business to throw away [__] money you
know so
i said i can't bet the yankees and i
can't be [__] cleveland because i
don't know if they're gonna
if they're gonna show up or not who's
gonna [__] with the yankees you never
know who's gonna show up [__] willie
mays could show up or like uncle joey
could show up i can't play baseball so
i said [__] it the line was over on 10.
listen if you got draftkings do me a
favor you want to win some quick money
i'll teach you how
don't tell don't tell nobody you heard
it here you ready
you open up the lines for baseball
there's some inside information i'm
giving you [__]
you open up the lines for baseball
you see who's got a heavy over like look
at all the over and unders right you
know for you people who don't know
gambling over and under is the total of
the game
you can bet whether it's going to go
over or it's going to stay under right
like i'm the king of sunday night
football
because i don't bet a game i bet the
total
and you go opposite of what they're
thinking so if you're gonna bet two
highly offensive teams go to under
because you've never seen a bookie with
a part-time job everybody in their
mother's gonna bet that so you might as
well bet against the [__] grain and
bet against everybody he's betting on
that's how you win [__] getus
so i can't bet cleveland i can't bet the
[__] yankees like what what am i
gonna do here i looked at the over and
under it was 10 good
i [__] put 25 bucks in just listen
guys just
for the excitement i forgot that my
daughter had a game i wanted to watch
the game just for a little while just to
you know maybe see him in the [__]
front bleachers wherever the [__] he was
sitting
next thing you know i [__] put the
over and i forget all about it
i go i go to a game i do a bunch of [__]
i come home and i open up the computer i
won i was like holy [__] when i opened
up the computer they were winning 10
nothing i hit the [__] the over
just with the cleveland indians they had
10 overs so i was pretty [__] excited
about that
that was my weekend that's it i watched
uh honeymooners
saturday night sunday we went to the
saint gabriel's uh carnival [__]
tremendous
listen man
except for the [__] one guy
there was a a guy that was running a
ride that had a black eye let me tell
you something if you're working at a
kid's festival
and [__] you got a black eye it's not
going to be i remember when i was
pulling my daughter in the gates and i
saw his black eye i was like
like what the [__] really these carnival
workers again i mean they hit the rock
bottom with this there was one carnival
work with a black eye and then i looked
at the other ride
and the [__] was out there
surrounded with 20 kids smoking a
cigarette like he was the world's most
interesting man i'm like this is [__]
up
and mothers were looking at them weird
like i didn't say you know what am i to
say something i just looked at them and
said jesus christ
you're smoking a [__] cigarette out
here you're surrounded with 20 [__]
kids but
those carnivals just get the worst
[__] uh
you know they get the bottom tier of
[__] people not not that i'm some
[__] uh nobel prize winner but [__]
you don't see me showing up in places
with a black eye and a missing tooth
that's when you know there's been a
problem the week before well it could've
been the night before who the [__] gives
a [__]
the one thing that happened that was
pretty interesting
saturday night i got a call from eddie
bravo i called him in the afternoon to
check up on him
and he called me back saturday night we
had a [__] great talk about [__] and
it made a lot of sense because
we'll get to what where this story is
going
you know he checked in with me and we're
bullshitting about that weed smells good
jesus christ
uh
that's some [__] ziki weed that's a
rocky road
from the ziki family only
at [__]
ice cream shop [__] that's like
30 percent they'll put a [__] he'll
give you that dead eye the other night i
smoke some weed from zika had the dead
eye you ever get that dead eye like you
can't [__] shake it and [__] i had
dead eye from some weed i didn't know
what the fight was like a half a
fentanyl joint oh whatever the [__] it
was
i was [__] up my [__] i had the
dead eye but anyway i was talking to mr
bravo my brother from another mother and
i
a lot of [__] [__] happened this
weekend to be honest with you a lot of
uh
mental [__] that i had to break through
i'm doing a lot better guys i i feel
i can't tell you where i was and i can't
tell you where i am you guys have to
figure it on your own if you have any
doubts
just turn on this podcast from last
october november december i didn't know
what was going on my head was in my ass
and my mental issues were [__] bad i
didn't know what was happening and you
know you never want to admit your
weaknesses
you know but you have to you have to
look at your weaknesses
and go what the [__] how do i make my
weaknesses stronger you know what
and my weaknesses on this one was the
move was a lot bigger than what i
anticipated
um
you know i lost a lot of friends with
the move i had to break a lot of
patterns
uh you know my adventure with my old
friends here you know
when you have old friends for 40 years
with a guy when you take a guy like me
my loyalty takes over
and i don't remember anything but the
good things they did for me you know
which is nothing wrong with that
and uh
i stayed loyal to a lot of my friends
here of of you know when i was a kid a
lot of you guys know that's no secret
and i stayed loyal to them
because of what they had done for me
growing up
but i stayed loyal to them over the
years not knowing the men and women that
they had became you know
so when i got back here i was expecting
the people from 1983
and
i got the evolution of that you know so
a lot of people
changed just like i changed i'm not a
thief anymore
these people or whatever they were in
their lives where they were hustlers
like me whatever they changed and
somewhere along the line we just don't
click anymore i was very sad about that
but it's a part of life
it's a part of that's what happens
sometimes you know you can't keep all
your friendships and tax you know i have
a couple buddies that had mental issues
that it really uh
[__] with me you know like
i had the mental issues too but they had
mental issues that were like accusing me
of robbing something [__] like that i
was like nah this is too deep you stole
my picture in 1982 i i can't i can't i
can't deal with that that was 40 years
ago i hope by now you got yourself a new
picture because jesus [__] christ you
know so
it was one of those weekends you know i
realized that
uh the thing with comedy was i said
goodbye at the comedy store i missed the
comedy store how can i not
how can i not and why should i feel bad
because i missed the comedy store it was
23 years of my life
you know take away seven that's still
[__] 16 years of your life what did
what do you think is gonna happen you
ever have a job for 16 [__] years and
quit
it it overhauls your [__] brain you
know so
um
it was uh that was
what was great about the weekend you
know i went back to acupuncture
and that's been [__] great she's
you know i had to go back to what i was
doing back there when i was feeling good
what happened when i got here what was
taken out of my life what was put into
my life you know what was
removed from my i mean all these
different things i had to look at and i
was like wait a second i started feeling
shitty when i stopped going to
acupuncture
maybe i should get back to acupuncture i
looked i asked around dog i found the
right lady
the first time knock on wood thank you
god for hooking me up with her because
if you hook up with the wrong person
that's a [__] nightmare she took care
of me the first week this week i'm gonna
do a little cupping a little needling
get some circulation going you know what
i'm saying and that's what it's all
about i'm just trying to stay healthy
i'm not worried about what's going on or
what's not going on or vaccine passports
i don't give a [__] i'm not traveling i
don't need to even think about that [__]
i'm gonna stick around my my business
and get stronger get healthier the book
is going [__] just great
you know what's crazy that i could tell
how much my life changed by writing this
book
because
i gotta be honest here the first [__]
eight chapters it gets uncomfortable to
write guys
i i wish i could tell you that it's fun
to write about your [__] life it's
not you gotta think back and you gotta
drag dogs through the mud again and it
sucks dick
there was mornings when i was on the
phone and i'm like why am i telling this
[__] story this is horrible
whether it's finding my mother or dead
on the floor or [__] scene somebody
gets shot
these are all horrible stories but now
i'm starting with comedy
like we're talking about the beginning
of comedy and i could tell the
difference in the chapters
i could tell that my happiness was
picking up it's it's
it's been a [__]
nightmare
and a pleasure doing this [__] book
it joins my memory
it brings me back to different
situations some of them i don't want to
think about but some of them you have to
look at and go [__] i learned a lot from
that [__] situation you know i
learned a lot so
back to the conversation with eddie
bravo when he called me the other night
i was happy to hear from him you know we
were just talking he was in uh
he was in kansas city on friday and
that's why when i saw the picture he was
doing a seminar and giving somebody a
black belt
i said let me give this [__] guy a
call you know i had i had a great week
all together with so many different
[__] facets so
i [__] uh
saw that he was in kansas city and i
[__] miss eddie you know just
just the conspiracies and all that [__]
they're [__] hysterical
so i call them up in the daytime i get
no answer he calls me back saturday
night i think i'm watching the [__]
ufc saturday night no bets on the ufc i
don't even know how to [__] people i
knew rachel pennington that was it i'm
getting [__] old
and uh we were talking and he was saying
that he was in uh omaha nebraska he
wasn't at the funny bone he was at a
different club he was with sam they were
doing that tinfoil hat stuff
and he was saying that you know
he's happy to go up on stage that he's
not expecting anything no you know it's
like me with the guitar i love playing
it because
there's no expectations i'm not looking
to get on hbo with the [__] guitar
i'm not looking to get in the back i
can't even play the guitar standing up
that's how bad i am i gotta sit the [__]
down like a country [__] [__] singer
you know
but
that's what it is i'm not good my
fingers you know i everywhere
you know but i stick with it it's
therapeutic and i [__] enjoy it you
know um
i never really hung out with a guitar
player like i never really hung out with
a guitar player so what eddie was saying
to me basically was
that
you know he had just gotten on stage he
opened up for sam and sam was on stage
killing he put the phone out for me to
hear sam and she was great
and uh
when i was talking to hedy he goes you
know what did i expect
he goes all those years i hung out with
you and joe
and ari and duncan and i listened and i
sat back i mean
i gotta say
i think
anyone on the road with us for maybe
three or four years
this is when we had the entourage
[__] uh
tour you know it was joe me duncan
redband tate
eddie you know so when you're around it
so much
and you hear about it's like eleanor
eleanor was around it for so long once
she got into it she picked it up like
nothing because she'd been around it
she heard people complaining about it
she picked up all the uh
idiosyncrasies of
comedy you know that's what you have to
cut through the [__] chase you know
sometimes sometimes you might try comedy
and it might not work out for you
but then you start talking more comedy
and you get like a different experience
you watch it more and now when you try
it again it'll work out for you you know
never quit never say well i'm not gonna
do it because it's not working out for
me
but that's what he was saying he goes
you know
it's crazy how i picked up all those
things
just from hanging out with you guys all
those years and then watching you
going to the store and watching you
eddie was always at the [__] store
all those years just watching and
watching and you know it's it's i never
even thought about it you know i never
even thought about it's like
me getting a job at a fight it's like
when i worked at my mother's bar you
know when i was a kid it wasn't an
official job it wasn't like i had to be
there from three to nine i would just go
in and there was no kids around
i would do some [__] work but while i
was there
listening to music listening to [__]
this this guy talking different
entertainers coming in
i would take the [__] conga drums and
play that's all part of my entertainment
experience so i had been entertaining
people since the beginning of [__]
time i didn't even [__] know it i
don't even know what [__]
entertainment is
so when i was talking to eddie it was
funny because i said to him eddie it's
it's interesting that you called and the
other reason why i was thinking about
eddie is i took a private i finally took
a [__] private
uh
one of my friends
came down
uh he's a brown belt and he brought some
mats with him
and we went
in the [__] garage
at his house and we uh [__] around a
little bit and
we rolled i was out of breath
i almost died i was busy
but i gotta tell you something man i
[__] miss it
my legs were [__] sore
my lower back was hurting
but it's so weird that i hadn't
done a [__] i hadn't swept anybody
i hadn't had a man on top of me i hadn't
been on top of anybody it's going close
to 20
[__] months
21 months i haven't rolled or anything
nothing
nothing not a hip escape
no nothing when i you know we did like
stationary hip escapes where you don't
[__] go down the mat i mean it was in
the [__] garage we was gonna do three
hip escapes and then turn around so i
did a couple hip escapes and then we
just practiced like a [__] uh
a hip bump sweep you know just to get my
legs going that's why my legs are so
[__] you know i wanted to see how the
brace worked on my right knee i had to
put two braces on there i can't [__]
kneel down
but it's so crazy how i thought
i would a i was in really bad shape
b i would be really winded
and c i wouldn't remember anything
listen after the first time that he
swept me and my balance was off after i
got my balance again and [__] on the mat
i was really impressed with what i did i
was very [__] impressed
after 20 months not remembering
not even fun and i don't do [__] i watch
a hodge gracie video once a week some
nights i'm bored and i just watch my
[__] jiu jitsu idol
hodge gracie do his [__] thing
so it was funny my buddy
[__] uh
helped me out i was over there was like
a 45 minute we rolled like two three
minute [__] rounds nothing
i just wanted to get back going see if i
could even hip escape
see if i could even move on the mat
listen i'm no eddie bravo i'm no hidra
gracie i'm no joe rogan
but i have to go to jiu jitsu and i'll
tell you why
i need a hobby
i don't have any [__] interest
my wife asked me this she goes can i ask
you a question
i've been with you for 21 years
what are your interests and i go
drugs
i
i don't know
i don't have any [__] interest that
was my
weakness in life i have no interest
maybe you collect stamps
maybe you collect butterflies i don't
know maybe you collect cars maybe you
work on cars
i have
zero
[__] aptitude for anything
zero do you understand me
zero i really want a major d job i don't
know anything about [__] wines
and i don't even want to know nothing
about wines i don't like people who
drink wine i'm sorry i i hope i don't
offend nobody you wine drinkers drive me
crazy with your [__] vineyards and
whatnot but i'm sorry i'm also an old
man i'm sure i drove you crazy with my
reefer talk and all that [__] so i i i
get it but i'm not a [__] wine dude
wine people drive me [__] crazy i'm
not gonna lie to you especially in new
jersey i don't know i was gone for 30
years or some people drinking wine
where's the bud light where's the miller
where's the radioactive beer here all of
a sudden that bunch of wine drinkers now
i'm going to a vineyard in jersey i
didn't know there was any [__]
vineyards in jersey but i wouldn't be
too [__] happy about drinking a
[__] grape out of this [__] i
don't mind the tomatoes but
you know i'm not a wine [__] drinker
so i can't do that
i can't [__] work you know i could
get a job with the felony i did find
that out like some corporation could
hire me
they got second [__] chance whatever
the [__] it is for people i'm thinking
about doing something like that but i
have
zero interest i have zero
experience and anything else but mixing
drinks which i don't want to [__] do
at my age now i can't imagine being at a
bartender and dealing with [__] drunk
people at this point now i can't do that
now
i
listen
i would love to [__] learn how to lay
brick now or whatever
i'm too [__] old i i gotta carry
bricks and [__] i'll die i'm 58 [__]
years old i'm two years from [__] 60
and i'm looking to start a new [__]
career i really am
i'm looking to do [__] something yeah
somewhere along the line i'll get back
on stage and i'll crack some jokes by
the time we get to phoenix you know i'm
saying if you're waiting for me to
[__] get on stage don't hold your
[__] breath i i just don't see it i
don't see the organic
in it you never know i might just pop up
on stage wednesday night and tell a
[__] story somewhere but it's
doubtful don't expect it right now
you're all looking at your calendars
where's it gonna be i know where i'm
just [__] with you guys but it's the
truth i don't see it [__] happening
but i got to pick up something i got to
do something else with my time i got the
podcast twice a week i got my daughter
i've taken the kickboxing yeah you know
i'm a [__] chauffeur all of a sudden
i take it a [__] i go to a baseball
games i go to her events this afternoon
i'll catch up with them after school you
know i try to do the best i [__] can
but there's something missing from my
life so i got to do so i got to figure
out a [__] gig
so i gotta figure out something i'm a
little bored
i can't lie to you people i'm a little
lonely at times you know i'm surrounded
with kids
and parents you know i'm still a [__]
savage from time to time i still have
savage [__] thoughts from time to
time so
you know so i got to do something so i
figured
the best way to get out and meet people
you know i don't want to meet people in
a [__] bar
because that's not what i want to do
i think i'm just gonna join a jiu jitsu
school so that's why i came up with my
mind i was just gonna take privates
with a friend of mine
but then i called my friend alberto
crane guy used to be on the podcast a
lot
he's a badass uh
tactic tactical fit in the sky tick fat
whatever the [__] they call it
that fit i don't [__] know
so on my days off in the gym sometimes i
actually get the club bells and just to
work out whatever so i called alberto
the other day
i think it was like thursday i called
alberto and i'm like so this is fate you
know what i'm saying
i called that bird and i'm talking about
you know take fat my wrist you know he
always helped me work on my wrist
to open them up so when you [__] when
you're in jiu jitsu when you're on your
back you want to frame up or whatever
you want to get up and and put this hand
down to do a hip bump or whatever hip a
hip bump sweep whatever the [__] they
call i'm sorry for you jiu jitsu people
that are watching it and you're like
what the [__] he talking about you
know the hip bump when i grab the arm
and i'm trying to bump him that way from
a closed guard
so i called him just to see what type of
exercises whatever and we were talking
he goes listen can i call you back i'm
getting ready
for the rose gracie [__] seminar
i'm like rolls crazy rose gracie has a
school close to my [__] house
are you [__] serious
so he goes yeah rolls crazy i go he goes
do you want me to talk to me for you i
go whoa
i'm gonna do privates with this other
guy
just until i get my bearings back you
know i'm gonna start again this
wednesday
but i love to [__] join rose's
[__] school so
i guess i'm gonna [__] go to rolls to
school in old bridge i i you know not
right now i'm gonna just do a couple
more privates the next couple weeks
get my footing under me you know tuesday
monday i got weights
tuesday i got acupuncture wednesday i
got my private
thursday i got dick
friday i got weights again i try to lift
twice and then saturday and sunday [__]
around the garage and i hit the bag but
again that's something i do by myself i
gotta figure out something i could do
with listen man when you join jiu jitsu
i'm going to tell you something
my good good friends in la the people i
miss the most
in la are all jiu jitsu people from matt
baker
to brett over at subconscious to alberto
crane
you know yeah i miss a lot of my comedy
friends
but i miss a lot of my jiu jitsu buddies
in that way
jiu jitsu
was very [__] good to me i don't know
if you guys have ever even gone to a jiu
jitsu gym
whatever if you have a board or
tired or whatever the [__] you are if
you're looking for something to do
i'll tell you man when i joined jiu
jitsu
the benefits for me of jujitsu the real
benefit
was pulling me away from the hollywood
mentality
that stupid [__] hollywood mentality
you guys see and [__] like that
i didn't i was a comic but i wasn't
involved
in the comedy mentality
i was hanging out with jiu jitsu guys
you know when i would go to breakfast
and stuff i would see bread a lot i
would see alberto a lot i would see joey
alvarado a lot i would see the uh a guy
i used to do jiu jitsu with nick
papadakis
that he does uh
the sticks he's a black belt in the
sticks he trains with the dog brothers
and all that [__] i was friends with him
i spoke to these guys these guys
kept my powder dry comedians were my
friends
but the jujitsu guys john salami ricky
rocket from poison
these were all my jiu jitsu friends you
know
i mean when i was a ricky rocket we
wouldn't even talk about [__] music
or poison or brett michaels or why he
wore the bandana we didn't talk about
any of that [__] we talked about [__]
jiu jitsu like you know and i enjoyed it
you know i used to talk to i still talk
to heagan on the phone from time to time
so
for the last [__] year i've been
sitting here doing nothing with my time
staring at two geese
that are in the closet you know i had
like 22 [__] geese people giving me
ghees i gave a bunch of them away i kept
the machado ghee that my cousin gave me
and i kept my subconscious ghee out of
respect for [__] brett and i also
kept all my alberto crane stuff
because i love him with all my heart
also but that that's gonna be the
[__] key for me i think
is for me to join a jiu jitsu school
maybe go twice to start off with do
weights twice a week
and do jiu jitsu twice a week
you can't [__] beat that you know so
i was really in [__] shock
how well i did and uh
i have a plan now
and i'm happy you guys got to witness it
you know you always hear stories about
people like oh he did this he did that
no
on this situation you guys witnessed
me making this comeback me going back to
[__]
speaking correctly being funny having a
look on my face you know yeah i got
healthy over the year and i quit the
refund i came back to it blah blah blah
blah blah blah
but what really [__]
happened that's what happened the move
destroyed me you know the [__]
the comedy store destroyed me you know
i'm happy that i
nailed these things down
for a long period of time i was walking
around knowing something was bothering
me
but i didn't know what the [__] was
bothering me i had no [__] idea
now i knew what was bothering me he was
basically
rediscovering new friends [__] you
know
to move
you know
you know no more cryotherapy like i was
left with my dick in my [__] hand
like i had this full [__] day seven
days a week in l.a
and also and i moved to jersey and i had
to restart again a little by little and
i'm happy listen it took me a [__]
while between
the anxiety my [__] teeth my knee
hurt and you know i ran into a [__]
wall of
injuries which happens from time to time
like you know i didn't let myself go
under i was a little depressed at times
but
you know the weights pulled me out
my daughter pulled me out i'm grateful
for her
that you know when whatever the little
depression i was going through at the
time i would look at her and go how can
i be [__] depressed
i got the world by the [__] balls you
know
and that's the main thing you know
you have to really
like yet like saturday for example you
know saturday i
we had the baseball game and then i came
home my the yankees and then
my daughter played the two games then
after that
i went on my merry way and they went on
their merry way
you know they wanted to go uh to the
carnival a bunch of little girls went
and i was alone i was alone for maybe
four hours
uh me and my wife decided don't don't
worry about dinner i'm on my own tonight
i went over and got a nice little
pastrami sandwich and a nice condition
my jewish friends
they hooked me up when i'm [__]
lonely i ate a little sour [__]
pickle
tremendous little water no chips no
nothing like that i'm still watching my
way
and i came home and i was like you know
what man i'm [__] lonely
i'm alone you know
and i was like
but wait a second
see this is where i've changed and this
is going to help you guys at home too
because this is what we never [__] do
and i started doing it when i moved here
because i started hearing people
complaining
they're complaining about jersey and i'm
like timeout [__]
i just came from [__] california
you got something to say about
government murphy i i ain't gonna fight
with you
but why don't i give you a [__] plane
ticket to california and you could go
hang out with newsome for a couple weeks
and then get back to me [__]
[Music]
then get back to me [__] you know that
that was my big thing like i don't like
you know we don't ever see the big
picture me included i am the biggest
[__] guilty [__] around this
but yesterday for the first time i've
been doing it since i moved here
like people say something and i go you
know oh this pizza was cold today
obviously you haven't been to california
where the pizza sucks [__] everywhere
even if the pizza's cold here at least
has some flavor to it i'm not tasting
[__] mozzarella cheese that's not
even real mozzarella [__] cheese
it's like mozzarella [__] goat cheese
or some [__] so
i'm grateful for what's in front of me
me doing those grateful things what we
were talking about the other day with
catherine narducci
which was a great podcast and it also
brought me back
to smelling the grass and having this
talk with you guys
was being grateful for what you have
right now so yesterday yes i was a
little bored i was thinking saturday i
was like maybe i'll go see the captain i
was gonna go see the black crows
i called a friend of mine when my wife
was gone i go [__] i'm close to the pnc
center
why don't i just go see the black crows
jimmy florentine said i could pick up
[__] lawn tickets
for 20 bucks
they're doing the concert from cover to
cover the first album
which is a great [__] album
hot to handle whatever the [__]
and i hang out i call my buddy guy
he couldn't do it i must have called
like three people and they couldn't
[__] do it so i said you know mike
lives in philly he would have [__]
done i'll come anywhere really [__] yeah
you just gotta call me dude you would
have gone to the concert yeah i thought
you had plans with your family that's
why i didn't call it
it was all it was cool but yeah yeah it
was like a 7 30 show
it's 20 minutes from my house i don't
think all the way to met life it's easy
you could park
yeah you're out of there in 10 minutes
somebody told me it took them 30 [__]
minutes to get out of the meadowlands
tonight of guns and roses an hour and a
half for some 30 minutes an hour and a
half
i can't deal with that [__] i would have
a [__] heart attack so
you know but i couldn't find anybody
like in time i didn't think about it i
know why i didn't call you because i
didn't think about it till late i had
forgotten
my wife was gone my wife left at like
four
and i'm sitting here i ran some errands
i had to go to the supermarket i had to
go to pharmacy
i ran some errands i'm like maybe i
should go see the [__] black crows
tonight the black crows are [__] hot
and something's going on
they need money they sound [__] good
so i think
the two brothers got back together
remember they didn't talk to each other
for a long time things are bad all over
colvin's a [__] cocaine is a
[__]
so [__] uh
they're talking they're [__] jumping
up and down they're skipping rope
they're going on walks everything's fine
when you're low on cash you get along
with a [__] real [__] fast to
get your chicken cutlet fixed
so i got your dog
so i was gonna go see the [__] black
crows i was like man i couldn't find
nobody goes through the black cross and
i got depressed for one minute for one
second i go no i got no [__] friends
i go whoa
i'm feeling a lot better
i brought myself back from the [__]
crypt
because i was in a [__] crypt guys i
really was
i'll never forget when my friend brian
came over here
he was managing me for a while and he
came downstairs
when i was recovering from the [__]
knee surgery and we were talking you
know man to man i love brian it's like
the way i talk to mike or the way i talk
to lee
and i looked at him like oh there's
nothing i really want to do he was
talking about all these big plans
well we'll start this tour and this and
i'm like
it's not happening guy
well don't you want to do this not
really don't you want to do this not
really and that's when i realized i had
the beginning as a [__] depression
i called ari you know hari had gone
through it before
and i'm like something's going on with
me i don't [__] feel right you know
and uh
the best advice he told me was
the gratitude thing with steve simone
just wake up in the morning tell
yourself five things you're grateful for
and i'll tell you what man i've been
doing them
ever since i talked to you guys about it
on the [__] podcast
and it's worked [__] miracles man
i mean when i first started this podcast
with mike
if i to describe it to you guys my
insides were like cloudy dark clouds you
ever see dark clouds outside that's what
it felt like those puffy ones
that's how i felt like man i and i was
getting up out of bed i was showering i
was worried i was doing what i had to do
i just was not feeling i didn't have
control of my thoughts
it was just horrible so compared to how
i felt
to compare to how i feel now it's a
million [__] dolls and i'm very
grateful
that i [__] did it and i walked the
walk and i journaled
and i did what i had to [__] do you
know i have no
[__] regrets about comedy or anything
let me tell you something uh
two nights ago three nights ago i was
waiting for my wife to come downstairs
and i was just scrolling through the tv
and i hate to uh talk about it again but
the rick james documentary is on
and it was starting from the beginning
and i watched the first i don't know 30
minutes
my wife even said i didn't watch this
part let me watch it with you
and we were watching the first 30
minutes of it and this
one thing i'm very grateful for that i
did in my comedy career that a lot of
people don't do
and they can't really look in and say
that they did was
i really put the work in
one thing that i realized about rick
james when i watched that documentary
why i enjoyed it so much
why i pushed it on you guys you know
was because i related to that
documentary in so many ways
i related to him being a criminal at
times
i related to him running numbers when he
was a kid you know i did that
i related to when they called him a
survivor because i was survivor at times
you know when i first got to l.a 97 i
wasn't making no money as a comic if you
want me to lie to you
and tell you the truth i was i was
getting
uh
you know like when you get algorithms
like i was getting big bursts of money
and then nothing for six months big
burst of money and then nothing for six
months like i had booked like a
commercial
[__] like that but when i would on those
down ends guys i'm not gonna lie to you
i sold coke
that was what i did
i sold i did whatever i had to do
to pay the rent
not to let my wife down not to let my
friends down
they didn't know rogan didn't know red
men didn't know a lot of people didn't
know
these were deals i was cutting in the
side i still remember
selling an agent to pound the weed
like every week he was my agent like in
2000 and 2001 his name was greg you're
real [__] slimy [__]
i was selling him a pound of [__]
weed and i swear to god i still remember
pulling away
and going where the cops
like where's the undercover [__] cops
where are they the [__] uh
where the [__] are they to [__]
arrest me i mean i was doing
some wild [__]
from 97 to 2000 2001.
whatever i had to do to pay the [__]
bills it didn't matter to me you know i
i sold coke i sold pot
you know i i did a lot of [__] [__]
you know and
that was what it was when i started
coming in 91 i wasn't working
after uh you know i divorced my wife
i lost my job as a roofer what the [__]
do you think i was doing yeah i hosted a
car wash
i delivered chinese food which i'm
thinking of doing again i went to get
some chinese food the other night
they're looking for a part-time driver
and i asked the lady just not to let her
know that i'm a loser i go hey i have a
nephew that's uh looking to drive what
nights do you need to drive
she said like three nights a week i got
a little deliveries all around here
she goes yeah pretty much all right so
i'm gonna go again
maybe tuesday if the sign's still up i'm
gonna [__] apply i got a clean
license
i just need something a couple hours a
night
just to get me out of the house just to
giggle a little with people i would love
to see people's faces when they open up
their front door and it's me delivering
that [__] chinese food you know what
i'm saying i'll bring some [__]
reefer with me give them a little bud
you know take this with you for that
thank you for ordering chinese food from
uncle joey that's why i want a major d
because i told the warm restaurant i go
listen
i'll twit that [__] i'll tweet that [__]
but i'm mature d in here i have people
in this [__] every night i'll be
doing five minutes a night in the middle
the guy's like well you have no wine
experience
well what am i going to do it looks like
i'm not going to be a [__] matridge
but that's the the main thing that i
enjoyed that i'm really proud of
there's something that's really i think
that's made me
different than a lot of the people i was
hanging out with
and not in a bad way
and i'm not saying that a lot of them
didn't do this
i could tell you a lot of people who i
saw them
i saw with my own eyes bust their
[__] hump
the biggest one being bill burr bill
burr's a hard worker
i knew bill from 97 man and that dude
worked
bill is where he's at because of his
work ethic
you know rogan's got a tremendous worth
ethic you know
so many people have had a great work
ethic
but i'm gonna tell you something
part of my success
part of my happiness today
it's like sinatra said i did it my
[__] way after watching that rit rick
james dock again the other day
you know what i thought of i thought of
all the things i had done i've done
voice overs
i've created shows
i've done stand-up
i'm a storyteller
i've done television i've done i did
[__] general hospital
can you [__] people believe uncle
joey the general [__] hospital
you're like joey come on stop pulling my
leg that's right [__]
benjamin brought
noah [__] drake what's his name
jesse's girl
that good looking dude what's the
[__] the guy who molested a bunch of
chicks
uh from [__] uh
he was in every [__] tv show and now
he got in trouble he had an acting class
him and him and the pot smokers did the
pineapple express oh danny masters no
that's that's the 60s
that [__] going to jail for
rape
yeah um
i know you're talking about your baby
but those dudes
what was i talking about anyway i forget
now i don't [__] know
i don't [__] know we're going back to
the old days when i used to get so high
i can't remember nothing but i didn't
get high today i can't get high in the
daytime holy [__]
i tried it two weeks ago cannot do it
it's over but my nighttime eyes oh my
god
i got so i got so stoned last night i
had to go in the garbage saturday night
and take the half commission i threw
away out of the garbage
that's when you know
you're [__] stoned my friends i told
you saturday night my wife went to the
[__] uh thing
and i had four hours alone i go you know
what i'm gonna go eat dinner with the
[__] jews i got a pastrami and i said
let me get a kanesh i'm not gonna eat
the whole [__] thing i usually eat
half and i put a half away from my wife
i said you know what i don't want the
rest of the commission it was [__]
good
sometimes when something's too good i
just throw it away because i know i'm
going to [__] finish the whole thing
and the canisius like 10 points i didn't
have 10 points left so i only get half
of it sorry charlie
saturday night i got so [__] stoned
i had to go upstairs to the kitchen
go in the garbage
and i'm like please
tell me i put the knish back in the
container because sometimes i just throw
them back in the bag i actually put it
back in the container
and then i [__] threw in the bag
thank god i wanted that garbage i took
the container the konish was cut right
in half perfectly i put in the nuka for
three minutes not even three ten seconds
and i put a little [__] brown mustard
on it
i slept like a [__] baby you
understand me that [__] knish had
valium in it like a [__] that's
why i love the jews memories of
auschwitz they don't [__] around jack
you can't sleep we'll [__] we got the
recipe for you [__]
but anyway i don't know what the [__] i
was talking about it's [__] monday
it's a beautiful day to be alive we have
a great [__] week coming up
laughing gas is back [__]
i'm [__] real they're back they're
[__] selling and we're gonna go into
some new stores in san diego and [__] if
you have uh [__] uh
dispensary and you want your we you want
uncle joey's authentic
real laughing gas in there from the ice
cream shop contact the ice cream shop
they will put it in there and they will
also put you on my personal
laughing gas [__] instagram page for
everybody to see and i will mention you
[__] weekly on the podcast to
let people know where my wheat is at so
attention san diego within about two to
three weeks you'll have laughing gas
there you won't have to [__] get the
roller skates on and go up to studio
city all right [__] you know
uncle joey's taking care of you
wednesday night
is the premiere of the [__]
many saints in newark
i'm very excited you know uh
a couple of my friends bought tickets
you know they're paying all the dough
to go to the movie theater it's a shame
we can't sit together i mean
they've only given me two tickets you
know how that goes people
especially now with covert they're
scared that
but it's okay they're gonna charge
everybody else to go in there so it's
gonna be a a brain [__] but i don't give
a [__] i'm looking forward to it
you know man
after last week's episode with catherine
i realized what this hall was
this was it for me
this was
you know i've shot
three things
since i shot the sopranos
and i'm happy i shot him but i'm kind of
not because i really wanted to end
everything
with the many saints in newark just for
me just for me to say
after that i bowed out but it's too late
now i did the apple show i did greg
garcia's show sprung
and it's uh i don't give a [__] it's
work i got to keep [__] working
but i'm very proud of this movie guys
and i'm very proud i was in it
and all that hard work i did in the
beginning you know like i was telling
you guys
when you look at somebody's history you
know like when i was telling you guys
about rick james
working with emma's lake and palmer the
guy robert palmer and he worked with
neil young and he knew the guys from the
band
robbie robertson
and all those guys he was he also knew
uh
the chick i forget what her name is he
was friends with her
a canadian girl uh
joni mitchell you know he
he had done
you know it's it reminds me of me in
seattle with josh wolfe and brody and
tana manu and
and [__] uh you know mitch hedberg
and all those guys up there you know
that little
you know me and mike always talk about
open mic
open mics for musicians you know
it's so important
it's it's like daycare for a toddler you
know like when your kid
seriously you know when your kid hits
two
you're like [__] we got to get him some
social [__] skills he has to learn
how to share you know yeah he's got a
cousin but the cousins have [__]
[__] you could leave him with the
cousin half the day but that don't work
his aunts are [__] [__] the
uncle's an alcoholic whatever the [__]
uh
it's the same thing
with with comedy yeah
you should be in a comedy club but you
should also be
you know at bars doing comedy at the at
the lowest [__] levels
that on the way home you're like i can't
believe i was in there what is going on
with my [__] life you know that
that's how you should feel but that's
okay
you have to at least you could tell
somebody i played it listen how bad did
i feel when i used to do the bus rides
you got to get on a disney bus
from [__] sea caucus new jersey
to port authority in new york and do
stupid [__] jokes for people how bad
would i [__] feel do you have any
[__] idea how bad i would feel i'd
feel pretty [__] shitty because i was
i was getting paid to eat a bag of dicks
i get it
but you're not eating a bag of dicks
you're gaining experience
so when you go on to do other things and
somebody hires you you don't make a
[__] jerk out of yourself 10 years
later i'm as experienced as it gets
and i am very proud of that it's like
when you read about somebody like prince
that played every instrument on a
[__] song
like he played every instrument on a
that's
putting in the [__] work
that means he did it i'mma tell you who
else does that as crazy as he is when he
makes his music eddie bravo
plays every [__] instrument the drums
the piano the [__] skin flute
whatever the [__] you got
eddie's playing you know
and that was me i'm very proud of that
when it comes to me that i did it all i
dove in there
you know i remember doing marin i'll
never forget when marion call me he goes
i have an episode for you
blah blah blah to me was going to be
like you know i learned my lines
whatever
but as i was shooting it the way i dove
into the character
when i got in my car and drove away
if you don't think i was blown away
[__] impressed
you got another thing coming i was
[__] blown away i'm like where did
this come from oh
the three years acting clown i'm
exaggerating i didn't go to acting class
for three years i went to
acting classes for like five months you
know the the the [__]
five months acting classes
plus yeah if you look at my imdb
there's 50 [__] movies on there but
guess what i didn't learn [__] on those
[__] movies i'm lying to you
i learned the [__] on all the [__]
college movies i did which you guys will
never see and never get to see i must
have
done 25 college [__] films and guess
what
all of them sucked
i don't have a reel from not one of them
how many short films did i do i had to
be [__] 20
20 30 short films you know how many of
those reels i have
i don't want nobody to see that [__]
that [__] was terrible but i was in the
process of learning
and i didn't even [__] know it i was
getting frustrated
but there was no reason to get
frustrated i was gaining experience and
that's what got us here today
all that experience put into one and i
even use it towards the podcast at times
there's times i do things i go when i
[__] learn that oh
episode three or [__] whatever
my name is earl you know that's
where i get my [__] chops from
and i'm very [__] proud of that
that's one
thing i've always been [__] proud of
man that i i put in the work
and nobody could ever take that away
from me so if you get anything from this
podcast on a monday morning what i was
trying to say in this podcast that i
couldn't
was that put in the [__] work
you know never mind the universal take k
and all those cliche terms i use
never mind that
put the [__] work in there's a guy on
my instagram my patreon his name is
john every week this guy is doing
something different
and i admire him like this week he did
something like he was a warm-up at a
[__] college
[__] football game
you know last week he did a short film
the week before that he worked the
[__] theater play the week before
that he did a commercial you know he's
probably making peanuts he's probably
all nine union stuff some of it being
saggies in oklahoma i guess oklahoma put
up tax breaks and they're going crazy
down there with [__] but one thing i
admire about this john character is
that he's not
too good to do anything
i had a conversation with a friend of
mine before the pandemic two years ago
and i asked him why didn't he go to that
audition he's a young comic
always wanted to be gung-ho i want to do
this and so i asked him when they go did
you go you got that audition didn't you
go he goes now i didn't want to go
because i didn't want to be known for
being a fat guy go
i didn't want to be known for being a
fat guy either i ended up losing the
weight
but when i got into this
i was the fat guy
you take your shirt off you let your
titties go up and down people see their
hair on your nipples that's all a part
of it don't be embarrassed
when people laugh at you laugh at them
go a number one you didn't have the
balls to do it and number two i got
something that you don't have and that's
experience from doing it i did all that
[__] look at the first joe rogan cd and
i in there topless with my balls hanging
out
i did it all you cannot
doug
a half years didn't know i did a soap
opera happiest i had no idea i did
industrial videos in seattle you know
what industrial is when some guy's
talking and you're in the back make him
believe you're moving boxes for ups me
and josh wolf on a [__] saturday
morning one hour shoots [__] 125
and you gotta wait three months for the
[__] check
do it all
if you're gonna be a fireman learn
everything there is to be a fire
light a fire even a lot of fire go burn
a house down learn
you have to know these things inside and
out
you have to be confident you could put
me in any situation and i could be
confident the other day some lady came
up to me at the gym she goes hey man
i'm a cop i need a big favor from you i
need for you to make a video for us we
do this thing
and i go i go do you want me to do it at
home or why she goes you can do it at
home and then send it to me i go i don't
know what the [__] i'm doing
tell me what to say and we'll do it
right now
and she looked at me weird she goes
here and i go yeah right here i turned
her around i ruined against the wall i
go tell me what i need to say she told
me and i just [__] blurted out this
two-minute video
for the police and she's like i go thank
you cut
and she cut it and she goes
how did you do that
she goes i usually have to prepare for
like two or three days and write stuff
down
i made like some stupid remark to like
you know what do you think you're
dealing with joey bananas but when i got
in the car i go how did i do that
30 [__] years of experience 30 years
of you know what it's like to go see a
comic how many times i went to see
ralphie man he's like you're doing 10
minutes
and you don't even have it in your mind
that you're gonna do a set
and now you're about to go up on stage
in two minutes you gotta do some quick
[__] thinking
so all those things that i thought were
douchey to me and all that
they all come in later on and help you
so whatever you're gonna dive into this
week just remember one thing
put all your heart into it
you know listen
i'm a hobbyist guitar player
i play a few [__] chords i'm not
looking to go to open mics or nothing
i'm embarrassed but
if this was going to be my life
i'd spend my hours taking the strings
off and putting them back on you know
you know i do all that [__] because i
want to know the insides and out of what
i'm doing that's what i did with comedy
that's what i did with acting that's
what i did with writing that's what i
did with
you know podcasting that's what i did
with storytelling and i got the most out
of it and that's why today i consider
myself like a coral belt i'm a like
eddie said to me yesterday he goes
you're a [__] coral belt you and joe
and it's a it's a compliment
it's it makes me blush a little bit to
say it
but i gotta go back to what captain
narducci said it's the [__] truth
i'm a [__] coral belt so i'm gonna
this is what the [__] i do so
the message for the week is
whatever you decide to dive into
dive into it 159 [__] percent whether
it's the guitar
because it doesn't matter at the end
you're just getting that dude that you
think is ripping you off well he's only
giving me fifty dollars for the gig yeah
but you're learning something
and three years from now when you put
that [__] out of [__] business
that's what you're gonna do you're gonna
put him out of business with all the
things you learned
from all the different people because
you had
all these different [__] experiences
so don't worry about who's ripping you
off think about how you're gonna rip
them off
with your confidence you know when
you're around the ufc fighter one thing
i've always noticed about fighters the
first time the first time i really
noticed it was around b.j penn i was
busting his balls and he did not get mad
why
because he was overconfident
he could blow on me and i could [__]
die b.j penn that's how tough that
[__] is
but anyway that's the monday morning
[__] podcast that's today as joey's
joint
i hope you enjoyed the message
and i hope you got something out of it
i'm always learning some from it like i
said last wednesday's podcast
was one of the best podcasts i've been
involved in it was a
it was a [__] uh it was a podcast i
needed i needed to hear that from
somebody else so
i appreciate it if you haven't watched
it go back and watch catherine narducci
do not forget laughing gas is stocked
back at ice cream shop and the money
saints in newark will be out
on october 1st i will be
putting a screening together for my high
tier
patreon people i am going to hear
something
they would not give me the first week of
october because
obviously they want all the [__]
dough
so they offered me a weekday which
a lot of years will be can't go
so i'm trying to get it for a [__]
sunday
so you could all make it uh
and i'll keep your [__] posted
that's it and that's that thank you for
watching uncle joey's joint
and now for a word
for my [__] sponsors jack
all right [__] thank you very
much for listening to the podcast today
i'm good today i was good and so were
you [__] it's monday morning i
want you to [__] look at the week and
say you're gonna suck my dick this week
but before we get out of here i want to
talk to you about a few things the joint
is also brought to you by
cbd lion
from the menthol gel to the capsules to
the bath salts to the creams to the i
mean listen
if cbd lion can get the cbd to you they
got every way to do it possibly you
could smoke it with the sour space candy
cbd
uh reefer that has no it won't get you
high it'll just
put cbd where it [__] needs it the
kinesiology tape listen i can sit here
for hours
and go off about cbd line
it's all up to you
go to the
website
cbdline.com
read
read the third party lab results
read what they have to tell you about
cbd cbn
cby and you take it from there
order pressing code joey and get 20 off
and it gets delivered right to your
house with cbd lion the best cbd on the
market the best cbd ointment that i've
tried
they help me with my surgery and they
can help you too with any of your little
mishaps
cbd lion go to their website right now
cbdlion.com
press and code joey get 20 off delivered
right to your house the joint is also
brought to you by the best in the
business draftkings why do i love
draftkings so much because they're safe
they're secure they're reliable they're
the official sports betting partner of
the nfl and the ufc why do i like them
so much they're trustworthy and it's
[__] fun there's nothing wrong with
putting 25 hours on a game and enjoying
it and watching it this week we have
tons of action we've got
robbie lawler against nick diaz you got
ortega against volkowski
you've got some great fights on this
card you've got nfl football you've got
college football you've got baseball
you've got probate i mean listen
if you want action draftkings got it
it starts this week with ufc 266.
draftkings is off for new customers 150
free bets instantly just about a dollar
on any fight
before the main event what did you say
any fight before the main event what you
don't like the ufc i get it you don't
want to see men wrestle in bikinis don't
worry draftkings has you covered they
got great odds and promotions on
football
baseball playoff baseball major league
baseball and golf plus they got a casino
that's second to none blackjack roulette
[__] poker 21
baccarat chinese ants whatever
draftkings got it the official sports
betting partner the ufc and if you bet
at the nfl this week bet a dollar and
get 203 credits
they're not stopping draftkings is going
[__] off this season so download the
draftking sportsbook app today use promo
code joey to receive 150 and free bets
instantly when you place a dollar bet on
ufc 266
that's promo code joey to receive 150
free bets instantly if you rather go
with the nfl you better dollar on any
nfl game
they're going to give you 200
for a limited time only at draftking
sports for gap you got to be 21 older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only new
customers only
winnings paid out in the site credits
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details
now if you got a gamer in palm i don't
want you on here
call 1-800 gambler
if you're in indiana call 1-809 with it
if you have any problems i want you to
download the draftking sportsbook app or
the fantasy app right now
that's a lot of fun also download it
press code joey in
bet a dollar and get 200 in credits if
it's nfl 150 if it's ufc
i love you guys i want to thank
cbd lion i want to thank draftkings but
most importantly i want to thank you
[__] savages for always having my
back
i love you [__] stay black
tip top magoo i'll see you wednesday
the 22nd
[Music]
so
you